a new investigation unit is being set up
to hold Russians accountable for
suspected war crimes in Ukraine it's
based in The Hague in the Netherlands
and employs prosecutors from the
international criminal court as well as
colleagues from the European Union the
United States and Ukraine suspected
Russian war crimes include the massacre
of civilians in the city of Butcher and
attacks on Ukraine's infrastructure
Today We Gather here on occasion of a
truly historic moment
I would say an Epoch defining moment
when the Civilized world not only voices
but also shows by concrete actions that
accountability is what matters the most
we cannot tolerate the gross violation
of the prohibition of the use of force
one of the fundamental rules of the
international rule base order and a
Bedrock principle of the U.N Charter
well let's get more on this now we're
joined by Jeffrey Robertson a former U.N
war crimes judge and president of the
un's war crimes Court in Sierra Leone
and he's joining us live from Melbourne
Mr Robertson thank you very much for
your time the center has been set up to
investigate the crime of aggression in
Ukraine why can't the international
criminal court do that
because Russia isn't a member of the
international criminal court nor is
America or China the problem is that we
have a law against aggression a very
simple law you invade another country
you're guilty of aggression unless you
can prove that you did so in
self-defense now referee is obviously
guilty because it had no interest in
self-defense Mr pragosan pointed out the
other day the crime of self-defense was
a lie Ukraine and even if it joined
native NATO was not going to invade
Russia so Putin is guilty as is Russia
of the crime of aggression the only
problem is that there is no court in
which it can be tried because Russia
isn't a member of the ICC it can't be
tried through an ICC crime and so there
is no way of pushing Putin in jail even
if which is unlikely he was minded to
turn up it's the only way forward is for
the general assembly of the United
Nations all 194 States or a majority of
them to set up a court by agreement with
Ukraine and that would be an
international court that could try Putin
in absenter in in the absence uh he
wouldn't turn up uh he would send them a
note saying that they didn't accept the
jurisdiction of the court but if it were
set up properly by the U.N General
Assembly it can't be set up by the
security Council because Russia has a
veto it would veto any action of course
by the security card and and also has an
ally on the security Council China which
would veto reimagine any such action
taken against Russia How likely is it
that the United nation's General
Assembly can set up such a court
when he can set up such a court my court
in Sierra Leone was set up by agreement
between the security Council and the uh
Sierra Leone government so by the same
token the general assembly could adopt
the security Council position and sign
an agreement with the government of
Ukraine and that would give the court
and make the court an international
criminal court and that is what would be
necessary but you'd have to go further
and give it the jurisdiction to try
Putin and his collaborators In Absentia
with that undoubtedly Putin would be
convicted because he has no defensive
self-defense
has pulled out and today
Mr Robertson you saying that the general
assembly can set up such a court they
have done so before but do they have the
political will if you look at how the
general assembly has voted on various
resolutions condemning Russia's
invasion of Ukraine there are many
countries which have voted either to
abstain or have voted
um in in support of Russia essentially
well not many voting support only about
seven but those who abstain who lack the
moral conviction to go after a country
in the Head of State who kills children
kills children and kidnaps them as well
as killed civilians and blasts buildings
where innocent people die
they range from South Africa
who lost all the moral position won by
Mandela India and all those sitting on
the fence so what it may take to
persuade them is of course the ICC the
prosecutor prosecute Putin for
kidnapping children there will be more
atrocities committed by the Russians
right after the the other day they
killed 12 people in Pizzeria as it were
to celebrate Putin's uh putting down the
Mutiny by quigizing that's the sort of
mentality you have people who are out to
kill innocent people and it may be that
the good people of South Africa the good
people of India it may be the pressure
will be put on these Wishes the immoral
abstainers to get on the side of justice
and support the uh a vote to set up all
right Accord to deliver the case of
aggression Mr Robertson we thank you
very much for your expertise on this we
really appreciated that as Jeffrey
Robertson live in Melbourne